You know, Chelsea, I bet our students are very
curious about what this device is that you're wearing.
>> Yeah.
>> An external fixator, that's what it's called?
>> That's correct. Yeah. It's kind of hard to miss. When I was a
kid, I injured the growth plate in my arm. And as a result, my
humerus stopped growing. So I was missing two and a half inches of bone.
And recently I had what's called limb
lengthening surgery. Which involved an orthopedic surgeon
re-breaking my humorous. I know, it sounds awful. Attaching this device, and
then ever so slightly over the course of several months, I would make
adjustments to the device. Which would spread apart the bone and as
it healed it, just filled in that missing two and a half inches.
>> So, you have to make adjustments to this.
>> Yeah.
>> And you know, one of the things we talk
about is that whenever a design has to have external labels.
Somebody has to put on special labels. That's
a sign of poor design. And I see there
are several labels you have, and what makes them
even worse is that. You can't even see them.
>> I can't. So making adjustments is a very intimidating process. If I do
it wrong there can be serious consequences, so I asked my doctor to help me
out by adding these labels, but when I left his office I realized, oh,
I can't see the labels. So, yeah, I sit in front of a mirror and
look at the them, just to remind me
which direction and which bolts I need to adjust.
>> So you have to take a hex wrench and put it in here.
>> I do, in this tiny little hole. And you can't see it as you do that.
>> I can't. Yep. And some of the holes are so
close together that I can put the wrench in the wrong one.
>> So, you know, this is a good example of some of the design
challenges we face in the real world. On the one hand you'd say, well, why isn't
that design so much easier for the patient than
the physician? On the other hand, you know, if
you're making a million devices, it's fairly easy to
spend a lot of time and effort to make
it easy for the people who use it. But I don't know how many of these are made.
Not very many. And probably each one has to
be specially tailerod for the patient. For your particular problem.
>> You're right.
>> And so, there probably, there's no easy way to fix it.
I, in fact, I though about it and I don't come up
with an easy solution to make it easy for all the people involved.
External fixator is strange name. This would be an interesting challenge
for you, think about it. If you want to learn more about this
particular device, go to the instructor's note, it will tell you how
to get to the website to the company that makes these parts.